We know from our identity properties that we want to use a log of the same base
as we see for this exponent here. A log of base e is the natural log. Taking
the natural log of both sides gives us ln of e to the x equals ln of 46. Now,
conveniently, ln is the button on the calculator. So let's plug this in and see
what number we get. Any natural log of 46. And here is our long number.
Remember, even this decimal is rounded. But we're only going to look at the
first three decimal places. You know, the left hand side of our equation is
just going to equal x and that decimal we got rounds to 3.829. This should
really be an approximately equal to sign. Awesome. We solved a more complicated
exponential equation.